[Music]
charles is in greensboro north carolina
hey charles welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for taking the call
rachel um i was on the
building up seminar last night and
covered inflation high level kind of
definition there had a
question did you need deeper advice
budget wise like on certain categories i
mean
in our budget we're seeing food go up we
can eat out less
is it a horrible time to do some home
improvements we've kind of had plan
obviously koster up
our car replacement fund i've added to
that
just given the cost of these cars going
up so when we get time to replace it i'm
going to have a little more saved up
um and then all that said as that kind
of eats into our budget
um i'd like to introduce kind of the
first part there's certain areas of the
budget
or more advantageous to change than
others and then second part
if i run out of room anywhere else is it
a horrible time to adjust 401k uh we
don't have any debt but
uh just temporary during
short-term inflation
um no i would adjust everything before i
adjusted that
uh all these other you know these home
improvements and car replacement funds
and all that stuff that's that's all
zeroed long before you touch your 401k
15 going in the 401k it's not the time
to step out of that
uh that's panic yeah not step out you
know just well or even even adjusting it
down i wouldn't i wouldn't no
but um i i think the main thing you need
to adjust for more than anything else is
your your timing on a large purchase
like home improvement you may want to
wait
and let building supplies and labor come
down
because they're both out of control
right now buying a used car
if you don't have to buy a car right now
it's a horrible time to buy a car
absolutely horrible
and uh if you don't have to is not the
time to buy a car
um i'm not i mean i i like cars and i'm
not buying a car right now
not a chance so i'm just going to let
these like because it's just it's just
moronic it's just out of control
i mean the used car market and it's all
about what we were talking about last
night it's a shortage yeah it's a
shortage of vehicles and so when the new
mark when the new factories get back up
to speed and they're dumping new on the
street like they used to and it's not a
nine month waiting period for a freaking
toyota truck
how absurd
you know but when we get the people back
in the factory and we get those trucks
hitting the street again
or cars hitting the street again then
that's going to loosen up the used car
market but the used car market is being
driven up because the new car market has
microchips tremendous technology either
can't get the technology yeah so there's
going to be some adjustments and it's
not the time to do those two things so i
would put those off the main place you
need to adjust your budget more than
anything else other than timing is just
the stuff that's the reality i mean it
costs more it costs more to fill your
gas tank right now yeah get food and gas
rachel's right
your utility shouldn't have changed much
i'm not seeing those move much so you
just kind of look at what's the reality
of my budget and just map it out
this is the ramsey show